olá pessoal tudo certo
hoje vim falar de um projeto simples
muito simples
o projeto chama perna solidárias alto
vale tudo começou há 15 anos atrás
quando pesava 85 quilos mas não é minha
esposa fisioterapeuta cuidando de muitas
pessoas com problemas devido à obesidade
e falta de saúde e cobrava diariamente
em casa foto gordinho não vai faltar
só que tal ficar tem que fazer uma coisa
pela minha vida não adianta ela é bonita
nova né
tem que fazer alguma coisa aí comecei a
correr
o retal aí que começou aquela onda das
corridas de rua que agora tem tudo
quanto é lugar
ela foi pra joinville está meus pais
meus pais são de lá chegando em
joinville tinha uma corrida lá noturna
foi escrever na corrida chegando a
corrida me deparo nem na largada assim
com quatro ciclos é adaptados e as
pessoas felizes linhas de ciclo e tal eu
não estressa infernal o gerente
comercial todo mundo sabe o que quer
vender e acabei gordinho cabeça pilhada
anmp a correr lhe dá o link da pessoa
que as pessoas hoje estão me deu um
conselho cair um raio assim comecei a
pensar naquilo que o negócio legal e aí
deu a largada da corrida o pessoal
largando pessoal redor rindo e chorando
emocionado bacana e eu minha esposa
sempre fizemos é ações sociais mas é
aquela que a maioria que quem faz faz
nesse período de natal
o inverno é dia das crianças páscoa
só que aquilo assim aquilo é legal pra
mim sempre foi legal porém não me
preenchia porque doado dinheiro do
alguma coisa
satisfaz mas eu acho que do a tempo
satisfaz mais ainda
então eu falei que era preciso fazer
alguma coisa passando um tempo eu
correndo pensando naquilo aquilo aquele
sentimento fantástico
um peso que eu tava fiz o meu melhor 10
quilômetros até hoje pois a crescer um
pouquinho e continue aquele tempo ficou
melhor pra ver como que eu estava
pilhado naquela situação mas chegando
aqui de volta pra casa e no carro
conversando com ela bem animado com o
negócio não vão tocar vou fazer vou
fazer e tal aí chegando aqui é e até uma
corrida da unimed
aí na corrida eu liguei pra descobrir
quem era o contato que tinha aquele
projeto em joinville o cleiton e clique
em porto alegre na corrida vou deixar
morrer empurrando um triciclo claro
portaluppi pode vir aí eu me inscrevi
dele duas semanas depois ele colocado
consegue as crianças para correr com 135
que eu sou de joinville não conheço
ninguém aí eu falei consigo consigo sim
nem sabia onde ia conseguir aí rio do
oeste uma associação a panes que com que
apoia é pessoas com dificuldades na
família com vários é intelectual e
significados locomoção e tal
foi legal se leva lá você precisava de
quatro crianças que torna o projeto
mantém uma foto antes membros isso é
fantástico e vamos escrever conseguir
vamos fazer a primeira corrida teve
largada a a até uma semana antes foi uma
coisa assim brilhante para me esquecia
até da minhas metas da empresa quando
foi demitido aí peguei comecei a foi bem
para a corrida teve largada e empurrando
o meu atleta preferido desde o começo
odone e aquilo para mim foi
transformador eu num triciclo esqueci-me
toda a minha vida esquece de tudo aquilo
só focavam nem vi o sorriso das pessoas
viu sorriso dani meus problemas acabaram
naquele momento acabarão todos os
problemas e finalizei aproveitar esse
projeto vai ser aqui no alto vale vai
trazer pra cá eu quero não isso aqui vai
ser transformador
então logo em seguida andré recebi um
convite através de um paciente a minha
esposa para participar mostrar o projeto
jc&e a gente começou a gostar do projeto
eles fazem um desafio anual aqui uma
corrida deles e falou kaká participar do
projeto e quero é da corrida quer assim
tal então o seguinte cuidado esse dia
tal mas vou participar
eu não tinha um triciclo agora ferrou né
aí liguei pro cleiton aquele cara ali
não tem agenda
focado aqui não consigo fremil deus e
agora aí está mais um amigo meu lá de
são bento que tem os tecidos também
liguei para o lucas vai são bento
aí o lucas falou nunca vou ambiental
beijo na minha e eu dormir na minha casa
também nem conhecia ele
estou indo levando quatro ciclos show de
bola chegou se a corrida será domingo
chegou sábado 9 da noite 10 não estava
chegando ninguém estou chegando
encostando encostou um c3 na minha casa
sem nada assim nem carretinha nada foi
ainda amanhã 9 horas ele está com 6 3 e
os triciclos
daí ele não tem 435 no carro e tem uma
barraca também tem mais eu ficar quanto
tem quatro princípios do carro em uma
barraca ea sua esposa tudo ali está tudo
aí falei olha só eu que falta essa
vontade deve que esse cara tem vontade
era fácil aí continuam aí no outro dia
fomos para a corrida na largada
fantástica fernando agora vão ter que
correr atrás do empresário tem contrato
de patrocínio pra gente conseguir montar
um projeto de vez aqui
aí teve mais uma apresentação não joga
se juntar o pessoal lá e comprar me doar
dois princípios nem eu tinha comprado já
o meu e o projeto começou a andar de
forma maravilhosa e teve outras corridas
e aí a gente é participar de corridas é
de forma voluntária é voluntária claro
mas é em corridas que quem organiza
convida gente de forma gratuita
então a gente não não partilhe com medo
que as pessoas cobram ao ingresso no
quadro há a participação está é a gente
ter uma corrida uma corrida que eu fui
correr com o dani e na largada pra ver
como é importante a acessibilidade na
largada da corrida eu tropecei é existe
uma competição entre os corredores que
empurra as cadeiras quem chega primeiro
é meio louca e até cortou para 2011
é óbvio é importante é participar
tá aí a nós pegamos teve a largada eu
não fui saiu patinei na pista
patinei cair quando eu caí a cadeira do
dono veio pra trás e eu me joguei de
baixo pra não tenham que não tem o
impacto e aí minha mãe achou tudo na
hora mas levantei daí mas o dano nenhum
e agora não perguntava no ano seguinte
faz qualquer coisa e cara
se tu quiser continuar correndo faz
qualquer gesto se tu não quiser
continuar fica bem paradinha o do sp
foi então vamos acabar era sangue na
minha mão correndo era a passou um carro
do samu do meu lado jogou uma toalha
vamos para a final vão parar seguir no
final da corrida do ano que vem atender
mandou direto a unimed fazer os pontos à
minha mão
então mas é muito emocionante é uma
coisa fantástica assim isso é né é umas
fotos do projeto projeto funciona da
seguinte forma eu tenho um grupo de
voluntários corredores que são pessoas
que conseguir trazer pessoas que não
corriam pessoas que tinha é
predisposição à depressão pessoas obesas
que estão cuidando da saúde para poder
emagrecedor
então hoje nós tivemos uma corrida a
maior corrida consegui fazer já porque
trouxe 135 de são bento de novo
emprestado não tenho seis ele trouxe
mais nove
fizemos a maior corrida a cnaa por quem
estava aqui na cidade houve uma
movimentação no centro foi fantástica
corrida corremos hoje com 13 e triciclos
tá então está movimentando trazendo uma
energia super positiva que pro alto vale
e também assim o lado bom é que as
pessoas que são os condutores são
pessoas que querem ter uma vida mais
saudável e outro a sul a ação crianças
pessoas querem tirar de locomoção que às
vezes não consegue indicar os seus
familiares ficam muito atentos a eles
não têm esse tempo disponível para isso
ea gente faz esse papel e traz essas
pessoas pra se socializar na sociedade
isso é fantástico porque eles se pegam
em locais que jamais eles estariam se
não fosse o pé na solidária
então tem umas fotos haqqani estão
dizendo tamanho do im
dá-lhes né o que o pernas solidários
mudou a vida do tango
mudou tudo na danni
ele já era uma criança feliz né
agora é e é muito mais feliz bem mais a
gente só tem a agradecer ao hospital
pelos solidários pela oportunidade que
eu vou dame a ele se sente útil
ele ama ela as sociedades
ele adora das sociedades quando o tema
corrido e fica ansioso ele não dorme à
noite fica toda hora me chamar medo de
perder a hora nem ele quer calar é
participar
a chuva só é tá lá não importa o
importante é participar e com semana nef
exibindo com medalha e troféu é danni
a gente tem aqui ó primeira medalha
segunda medalha dele me terceira medalha
e troféu né
o primeiro troféu que ele mais gosta
segundo o réu tudo guardado no quarto
dele tudo guardado gay que tem um amor
por isso o terceiro troféu dele não
deixe ninguém mexer mas que todo mundo
lê guê troféu medalha em uma bola que
ninguém mexer nem vai tocar nas medalhas
e então um rito gay agradecer é o pé na
solenidade pela oportunidade
ele fica muito ansiosa espera da próxima
corrida né
quando que vai ser a próxima quer
participar
então eram solidária z
a paixão por aí né ter ficado num herói
um herói pra ele na verdade e então
quero descer
o que é muito feliz e eu também né
será que ele usa também sou e totem
mesmo de agradecer muito pelas unidades
ao ricardo e estamos na espera da
próxima de dengue em que venha logo é e
muito obrigado pelas unidades da
oportunidade que tentada dano
estamos muito felizes muito obrigado
e esse é o doni
[Aplausos]
aqueles que rezam pela cara em tocar no
show
[Aplausos]
e aí eu deixo uma pergunta pra vocês
quem fez o dano ocorreu hoje 10 planos
de manhã com a gente ele acordou às
cinco e meia da manhã do domingo
beleza galera muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
queria agradecer muito à minha esposa
está pessoal você não vai matar mas ela
ela me ajuda em tudo em tudo